well many of us are wondering how we
would actually cope if we were forced to
at South fire isolate for a period of
months I seem to have bought myself a
Playstation at Alaska four days in
preparation so let's find out what it's
actually really like the SPS at least
the cameron has been self isolating with
symptoms of the virus so she joins us
from her home first of all thank you so
much for be on the program how are you
feeling thank you I'm still feeling
really very tired sore exhaustion has
been the largest symptom for me and I've
got a giant cough and not not a Flemmi
call that you would normally have with
cold so it's a sort of a cough
I've got aches and pain train round my
back mainly and my shoulders sleeping a
lot and I've had swollen glands over the
past few days as well but but that's
sort of dissipating a bit no you're
talking to us certainly no you fool a
lot better soon and there's no testing
for people in your situation is that
right but that changed last week I mean
I was on the phone to one one when a
number of times as symptoms developed
and at first I was told and my symptoms
weren't concerning just to carry on as
usual and then on Thursday night when I
called again with my cough has developed
at that point in time the doctor that I
spoke to at that point we feared me for
testing so I was expecting to have a
test then the next day I had a call from
the NHS in the afternoon and they said
that the strategy had had sort of
changed and that there was no testing
and after that day so I wasn't going to
be referred for tests so um I suppose on
the one hand you you do want to have a
test you want to know and a diagnosis
but on the other I think perhaps it may
be that they have to keep the tests for
people very much more vulnerable so you
don't want to take a test from someone
else who's you know much more critical
than yourself
it's definitely that balance as you say
I think isn't it to try and relieve the
pressure but also that make sure you
feel supported I mean do you feel that
you've had the support that you need
from the servants I think this the
service has been absolutely and indeed
did I know when I could when I called
back on Thursday evening I waited about
three hours first once but it was
because they work they were totally
inundated so I I think the service is
probably a capacity and people are
working absolutely right into clocks or
I can't fall I can't fall that at all
that they're doing an amazing job in in
this situation and I think it's
difficult because the the strategy and
the messaging appears to have sort of
changed and for people who have the
symptoms from and you know at first it
was a sort of Keep Calm carry on there
wasn't you know anything to worry about
just corners normal and then as things
progressed and and actually as my cough
developed then then that was totally
different one the thirsty evenings which
is understandable as symptoms develop
but you you feel a bit in the dark with
that and you don't know how long to
expect the symptoms for I've not not had
anything since been called on the afraid
to see that I shouldn't be getting
testing any more I'm at that point I was
taught that my husband and children
could carry on as normal but we sort of
just decided ourselves that they would
sail faithfully as well because you know
the public interaction we didn't want to
be putting people at risk and we weren't
really sure of how infectious it is and
whether or not I had already passed it
on to them so we didn't want to take
that risk with other people's health I'm
interested to know a little bit about
the reality of being self isolated I
mean you just mentioned that your
children have been self isolated - I
think it's for many parents that's
something that they would be worried
about how would that work practically is
it boring you watching a litter box that
so you've you know learning a new
language
[Laughter]
I've been trying to as much as possible
state and a different rim from them
occasionally they'll burst into the room
and actually I don't have to remind them
no you can't you can't come in here it's
really difficult you want your - I'll
give children you want to point you at
them and but for their safety and their
health then you're pretty much keeping
away from them I've been told to and use
a different bathroom and where possible
we like you've got a downstairs bathroom
making that I can do that other families
wouldn't necessarily be able to do that
and my husband's and basically being mom
and dad and just now I'm just trying to
make sure that let me keep separate so
it is very difficult time speaking to
Lex a lot now in my room on my own
I love everyone together
talking to a lake so I can totally see
that as a way of trying to keep up the
interaction and then just finally we've
seen lots of stories about people
struggling to get hold of essential
items and supermarkets and delays to
deliveries and so on and is that
something that concerns you as someone
who actually is in self-isolation
yeah well I made an order to the
supermarket but there's I mean I think
they're absolutely inundated as well so
if that doesn't come in till Wednesday
and there's special precautions that you
had to put on it to let that obviously
the driver and the delivery staff nor am
your predicament and so we've done all
of that and but we've got very good
neighbor whose life something's milk and
actually a bunch of flowers as well and
some sort of daily things on the
doorstep each day so that's really nice
because I think supermarket I think it's
going from a less become and carry on to
there's a bit of panic now and people
are really concerned so I think
supermarkets are been very any dated you
can't get a delivery for a number of
days is is why I find
I'm more concerned for you know elderly
people who might be on their own high
with it how would they get they get
supplies that kind of thing so I mean I
think for people who don't have any
symptoms who don't have the virus if
older adults are isolating then maybe we
have to be thinking about do they do
they need some help at this point too
and and and being much more community
and neighborly focused yeah definitely a
bit of advice I hope to be back soon
within the next couple of weeks anyway
and get back to normal and to be able to
help people and that's the thing with
the taste I would see if you had the
test you would know whether you tied it
and the period was finished I could go
back to work and then sometimes develop
again and I think my fad this at
universe we get confused on you you're
not quite sure but I think you just have
to take it a day at a time and see it
through and just check I can get it
every stage thank you thank you thank
you so much for coming on the program
especially when you're not feeling well
I hope you feel better very soon and
good luck keeping the kids at bay as
well thank you